welcome back to rmix logic data science
in this session we will introduce
biomedical data analysis techniques and
approaches that you can master and adopt
to help you conduct better research
the goal of this program is to introduce
the need for data science and
application to biomedical projects many
of such projects require a good
understanding of various omics data
types steps to process raw data and
structured for analysis as well as know
how to extract meaningful information
from such data sets to visualization
analysis and machine learning
importantly here you will learn to link
biological phenomena with data patterns
for meaningful interpretation
before we go on let's review the program
plan and objectives
the syllabus of the program is organized
into three different parts introduction
methods
and applications
in the introduction you will be prepared
to deal with relevant terminology and
key concepts to refresh your memory and
get you started
the methods part will give you a
practical sense of commonly used methods
and functions for analysis of mixed data
starting from exploratory to statistical
testing supervised and unsupervised
machine learning as well as deep
learning
finally the project section will offer a
sense of application for how these
methods are applied to real data sets
completing the full program will give
you the confidence that you understand
the analysis and can apply it
independently to a data set of your
choice
each session is designed to cover the
topics in a practical and informative
way
oftentimes these session videos are
going to be sent to you by email
in each session you will also find
additional links to asynchronous
resources that review and enrich the
cover topic
depending on how far you want to go with
the program you can choose to stay
within the scope of the syllabus or
explore beyond what is covered in each
session with asynchronous materials that
are included
in this session i will try to cover
everything you need to know to make the
most of your time and benefit from this
program
in the future we will also schedule a q
a session where you will be able to
submit your questions and get answers in
an interactive session before you jump
into the data science curriculum we do
recommend that you complete the
introductory courses which you also have
access to including the introduction to
bioinformatics bytes and molecules as
well as a basic overview of rn python
coding for bioinformatics analysis if
you're already familiar with these
topics let's discuss what specifically
will be covered in each part of this
program if a lot of what we are talking
about when we say words like
transcriptomics genomics metagenomics
does not really make sense yet if you're
not sure what omix data looks like and
maybe you have no clue what
dimensionality reduction really means
the first part of the program will make
sure that you're familiar with these
topics and understand the terminology we
will try to answer questions about
processing or preparing data for
analysis we will walk through the
concepts behind finding signal in noisy
data and explain why it is important to
understand how the molecular
characteristics of data objects can be
associated with a concept that we can
interpret
here you will find three main options
there's going to be a logical approach
which will be based on analysis that
will explain most concepts using excel
and the user-friendly t-bioinfo platform
you will have another track which is
called bioml in r for those who are more
familiar and comfortable with r and r
studio and finally you will see the
bioml in python which focuses on the
python programming language each one of
these courses covers similar topics
however the level of complexity and
challenges with syntax will be very
different we recommend that you take the
biomelogic course first and then decide
to finish either the python or the r
coding courses separately because the
syntax is quite different from each
other and it can become confusing if you
start working on both at the same time
coding exercises and syntax in each one
of the coding lessons will rely on
packages that have to be installed on
your computer to run
however we will also provide you with an
online environment where you can read
and understand the syntax run the code
on example datasets and gain access to
jupyter notebooks to develop code of
your own and submit assignments
ultimately you might choose to copy all
of the code and save on your own
personal machine
to make sure that everything is working
make sure that you're not assuming that
code will work exactly the same way
there might be many different technical
challenges for example you might need to
install python or r
maybe you will need to set up your
coding environment which includes
setting the working directory loading
packages and make sure that you overcome
the technical limitations which often
come up and are specific to your own
computer so the safest way is to utilize
the online environment that we provide
and after you are ready to transition
and you understand how the code works to
try and set up everything on your
computer
after completing this introduction we
will jump into machine learning topics
unsupervised and supervised learning as
well as feature selection these methods
are often used for various tasks such as
visualization organization of data
finding signal in noisy omics data as
well as things like predictive analysis
and feature selection to be able to use
these methods you need to understand how
they work what are their inputs
variables settings and available
packages that combine multiple functions
to make the methods easy to deploy
you will learn how to load data select a
method and run it to get an output of
that particular model and try to
understand what it found
then we will start our review of
additional analytical methods that are
useful for biomedical discovery
including network analysis such as
pathway analysis generalized linear
models that are used to distinguish
between expression profiles of
transcripts as well as deep learning
models that can be used for specific
types of situations to improve accuracy
and decrease feature engineering that a
lot of conventional machine learning
relies on we will also talk about the
need to combine various machine learning
models into a series of steps to achieve
more sophisticated tasks and finally we
will talk about different use cases that
can show how these methods that we
review have been used by researchers to
find meaningful insights in complex
experiments biological samples animal
models or even patient data
with the few examples that we review as
case studies you can then develop a
project of your own or follow
asynchronous tutorials to reproduce an
analysis that you can improve upon
turning it into a novel and personal
study on the omnilogic portal you will
find a more detailed review of each data
set that we use in our exercises with
additional tutorials method
clarifications and links to research
articles where the authors demonstrate
the utility of machine learning methods
for their own findings now let's take a
brief moment to explain what kind of
resources you will have access to during
the program and how exactly to use them
one of the major challenges in omics
data analysis is related to accurate
reproducible and effective processing of
large-scale data sets that represent
gigabytes or even terabytes of data such
large quantities prevents many people to
gain practical hands-on feel for these
pipelines which are critical to
understand where the data you analyze
comes from
to be able to do that we have prepared a
number of example projects that are
essentially demos these pipelines do not
have to run they don't use computational
resources and they demonstrate the
inputs and outputs as well as the logic
of analysis for each example you will
also find that a lot of these pipelines
are color coded and provide a very clear
explanation of each step with conditions
methods and settings that you have to
know for reproducible workflows you will
also get to practice all of this code in
the online console where you will find
predefined answers and you can try to
run the code simply by modifying it
according to what was explained in the
syntax section
you will find a lot of these clear
explanations in our courses for example
this course on introduction to data
science in python
and introduction to data science and r
you will find that many of the same
methods are covered but with little
variation in the way the data is
prepared
analyzed and the outputs that these
methods produce